working with marylin one word sublime I
have to like take a breath a deep breath
every time I talk to her that's what I'm
doing I mean you go toe to toe with her
though in those scenes my friend like
what was that like it's just an acting
juggernaut the two of you I mean it was
intimidating for sure I have to like
sometimes put myself back and take a
deep breath and go okay she's just a
person she's a human being but it was a
thrill and to get to sit with her and
talk about the script and work through
scenes was just like are you kidding me
as an actor all my life you know
worshiping her work and and she's just
as truthful and honest and genuine and
fun-loving as you can imagine my son is
dead
and I want answers why can't you answer
yes but you'll have some things I have
didn't you she just told me you guys
hung out and that you had not one she
said one glass of wine we had a couple
in Monterrey pizza we pizza pasta drink
wine talked about our lives it was
really fun well and I loved seeing you
here with your daughter on the carpet I
mean can we see her in big little eyes
season three oh I didn't know there was
a big little eye season could it happen
we didn't know to what happened I don't
know you know I never seen ever this was
a surprise and we we feel enormous it we
only locked it on Monday so Brandi knew
in our mind
I heard darker more intense but also
funny does it up the ante for sure
definitely and with the with muralist
character coming to town there's just a
lot of tension and muttering I don't
even like to chew I just shove them down
maybe you can give one named Warren so
if you can shut it - OH
and we're off lutely Blonde 3 have you
seen a script and if you haven't I mean
what do you want Elle's story to be in
this next chapter I think she's a very
beloved character you just want her to
go on a hero's journey like she does in
the first movie and I'm having a great
time working on it okay so script is
being worked on yes a script but we
haven't shot anything
I think it gives it a little something
extra we cannot wait for your show with
Jen Aniston what was it like to bring
her back to TV and what was the best
part about working with her again it's
such a great show I can't say anything
about it's about but I think it'll be
surprising for people I think they'll be
really it's very surprising and chin is
wonderful and again it's this great
female partnership I have to say it's a
theme in my life and past few years so
I'm just really enjoying the partnership
with other women I really respect and
admire reuniting in 25 years since
Friends this year by the way I was that
right it was so great it was such a an
indelible moment in my life being at
Central Perk and working with Jennifer
Aniston so I think the fact that I got
to go back and do it again it'll just
the great
[Music]